okay
there
folks i've just spoken with
prime minister netanyahu earlier today i
spoke with president al-sisi of egypt
minister prime minister netanyahu
informed me that israel has agreed to a
mutual unconditional cease fire
began in less than two hours the
egyptians have
now informed us that hamas and the other
groups in gaza
have also agreed in my conversation with
president netanyahu i commended him
for the decision to bring the current
hostilities to a close within
less than 11 days i also emphasize what
i've said throughout this conflict
the united states fully supports
israel's right to defend itself
against indiscriminate rocket attacks
from hamas
and other gaza-based terrorist groups
that have taken the lives of innocent
civilians
in israel the prime minister also shared
with me
his appreciation for the iron dome
system
which our nations developed together and
which has saved lives of
countless israeli citizens of arab and
jew
i assured him of my full support to
replenish
israel's iron dome system to ensure its
defenses and security in the future
over the last 11 days i spoke with the
prime minister six times
i've also spoken with president obama
the palestinian authority
or the once and part of our intense
diplomatic engagement
and i want to also thank the secretary
of state the secretary of defense our
non-national security adviser and
everyone on our team
for their incredible efforts to bring
this about this outcome that we're
about to see you know we've held
intensive high-level discussions
hour by hour literally egypt the
palestinian authority and other middle
eastern countries
with the name of avoiding the sort of
prolonged conflict we've seen in
previous years
when hostilities have broken out i
extend my sincere gratitude to president
el-sisi
and the senior egyptian officials who
played such a critical role
in this diplomacy i also preached
appreciate the contributions of other
parties in the region
who have been engaged in working toward
the end of hostilities
these hostilities have resulted in the
tragic deaths of so many
civilians including children and i send
my sincere condolences to all the
families
israeli and palestinians who have lost
loved ones
and my hope for a full recovery for the
wounded
the united states committed to working
with the united nations and we remain
committed to working in the united
nations
and other international stakeholders to
provide rapid humanitarian assistance
and the marshall international support
for the people of gaza
and the gaza reconstruction efforts
we will do this in full partnership with
the palestinian authority
namaste authority in a manner that does
not permit hamas to simply restock its
military arsenal
i believe the palestinians and israelis
equally deserve to live safely and
securely
and to enjoy equal measures of freedom
prosperity
and democracy my administration
will continue our quiet relentless
diplomacy toward that end
i believe we have a genuine opportunity
to make progress
and i'm committed to working for it i
want to thank you all
may god bless you all and pray that this
continues
thank you so much
[Music]
are you confident the ceasefire will
last president biden
right